zu verkaufen dass das glaubst die
pioniere der länder waren rebellen vor
gut 50 jahren wollten sie sich in erster
linie dem wachsenden kunstmarkt
entziehen und das zog sie in die wüsten
des amerikanischen westens
diese kunst passt in keine galerie man
kann sie nicht kaufen
nicht überm sofa hin
[Musik]
wer sie sehen will muss hinaus in die
wüste in die ebene in die landschaft
ende der 1960 er jahre begann die
pioniere der land art zeichen in die
landschaft zu setzen
sie waren inspiriert von den neuen
perspektiven welche die mondflüge
lieferten
der blaue planet in seiner vollen
ausdehnung
ihn machten die avantgardisten zur
leinwand zum material und zum spielplatz
für ihre kunst 1970 formte roberts mäzen
steinmassen zu einer riesigen spirale im
great salt lake in utah
460 meter lang gegen den uhrzeigersinn
und gegen den mainstream des damaligen
kunstbetriebs
michael heiser bewegte noch mehr an
steinmassl 240.000 tonnen für einen
spalt einen riss in der natur eine
begehbare skulptur in der man die wucht
des felsens erleben kann
bei den ersten land ort künstlern stand
das rebellische im vordergrund das
monumentale als verweigerung möglich nur
dort wo es platz ohne ende gibt in den
wüstenlandschaften amerikas
so wie das blitz welt von world of the
area in new mexico das größer ist als
ein quadratkilometer
[Musik]
ursprünglich wollte land ort die
landschaft gestalten in die landschaft
eingreifen sie umbauen
[Musik]
mit einem 40 km langen zaun dem running
fence stieß christo 1976 zumindest
längen mäßig in neue dimensionen vor
er war es der land art populär machte
kommerziell verwertbar zum event für
touristen wie auch hier am lago di leo
[Musik]
heute beschäftigen sich land art
künstler mit sozio kulturellen
fragestellungen der mensch in der natur
seine kultur im licht der globalisierung
das zeigt sich in der nördlichen
mongolei besonders gut an der biennale
landart mongolia eine der größten ihrer
art weltweit
dort wurde eroberer cengiz kahn einst
das licht der welt erblickte hat eine
internationale künstlerschar in
zusammenarbeit mit den einheimischen die
aktuelle ausstellung aufgebaut
jede landschaft wird zu einem großen
teil von ihren bewohnern geformt aus
dieser perspektive gedacht fördert das
wissen über die lokale bevölkerung das
verständnis für die landschaft sie
gehört zu den 150 eingeladenen
kunstschaffen so view die lebensweise
der nomaden fasziniert die schweizer
künstlerin als passionierte reiterin ist
sie besonders an den herausforderungen
der pferdehaltung interessiert haben die
pferde hier in der mongolei nie probleme
mit dem magen liegen dem kreis die
pferde in der schweiz haben das ziemlich
oft vielleicht wegen dem vielen gras
ein gemeinsames interesse über die
kulturen hinweg nur wie wird daraus
landart
[Musik]
sophie bio sucht nach einer
schnittstelle zwischen westlicher
moderne und östlicher tradition
andere sind da schon weiter wie der
niederländische sound künstler ronald
van damme er hat verschiedene
nomadischen völkern musikinstrumente
abgekauft und diese mit neuester technik
ausgerüstet es ist direkt mit der solar
panel verbunden
je nachdem wie die sonne scheint beginnt
es zu spielen und es entsteht diese art
von hypnotischen sound
sound ein hörbares wahrzeichen das von
der sonne orchestriert die
unterschiedlichen musikalischen
traditionen und länder verbindet
unterdessen hat die lausannerin zu ihren
ansatz gefunden sie will ein wort auf
diesen grünen hügel schreiben ein
mongolisches wort eine installation aus
lauter fahrrad lämpchen ihre idee das
lebensgefühl der nomaden soll auf
scheinen in diesem begriff in ihrem werk
ich verstehe es als etwas verbindendes
zwischen den menschen eine kunst werk
das diskussion auslösen soll nichts
fundamentales einfach entspannte
gespräche auf 30 x 100-meter leuchten
die kyrillischen zeichen zu bio bedeutet
galopp dazu ein fragezeichen
eine befragung über den sinn und die
notwendigkeit des gesteigerten
lebenstempo
[Musik]